queen elizabeth ii has passed peacefully
in her palmoral castle in scotland
how will this affect the economy
what will it mean for
the future of the commonwealth
and
what does operation london bridge have
to do with this
this
is what if and here's what happens when
the queen dies
since
1952 the united kingdom has lived under
the rule of queen elizabeth ii
that makes her the longest reigning
monarch in british history
multiple generations have never known
life with a different head of state
in the event of her passing there is a
well established line of succession
the queen's oldest son charles prince of
wales will inherit the throne
but will prince charles have the support
of the british public
could the end of the queen's reign mark
the end of the british royal family
for years information about what would
happen when the queen dies was kept
under very tight cover but these plans
are no longer secret
on the day of this traumatic event
operation london bridge would begin
a code name like this is not unique when
the queen's father king george vi passed
away that plan was codenamed hyde park
corner
operation london bridge lays out in
exact detail what to do from the moment
of her death through 12 days of national
mourning
first her private secretary would inform
the current prime minister
civil servants would say london bridge
is down on secure lines
the news of her passing would be shared
with the other 15 governments of which
she is the head of state and the 36
commonwealth nations for whom she served
as a symbolic figurehead
a footman in mourning clothes would
place a notice on the gates of
buckingham palace informing the public
of the news
all staff of the royal family would wear
a black armband on their left arm
this band must measure eight and a
quarter centimeters
from there rats the radio alert
transmission system would be activated
this cold war era alarm system was
designed to withstand attacks on the
nation's infrastructure
television coverage would begin
the media have their own nickname for
this situation
mrs robinson
all the main channels would pull their
regular programming and presenters would
be wearing black
but with social media there's a good
chance you would learn it there first
news of the queen's passing would
quickly pop up everywhere
it could sound morbid but the media has
days of coverage planned and content
including obituaries ready to go
if you happen to be on a plane at this
moment you'd hear the news from your
pilot
you wouldn't be able to watch any late
night comedy shows they wouldn't run
until after the queen's funeral
the queen's body would remain at
buckingham palace for 10 days and the
family would be spending time together
but for the new ruler there wouldn't be
much time for mourning
the day after the queen's death at 11 am
prince charles would be proclaimed king
on the tenth day officials from all
around the world would attend the
queen's funeral at westminster abbey
this would be a massive day of mourning
and hundreds of thousands of people
would come to pay their respects
even the british stock market would
remain closed this day
a ceremonial decision that could cost
the economy billions of pounds
of course this plan accounts for what
happens if the queen passes away in
london but
what if she happens to pass away abroad
well there's a jet from the royal air
force always ready to respond
it would carry the first call coffin to
bring the queen's body back to london
after nearly 70 years in power life
under a new monarch could certainly lead
to changes around the commonwealth
several nations could decide to finally
break their ties to britain and become
full republics
the monarchs could even be replaced with
heads of state elected on a rotating
basis
but the plans for operation london
bridge are as elaborate detailed and
controlled as the life of the royal
family
nothing is left to chance and that makes
it seem as though the future of the
monarchy remains strong
though in the wake of the death of the
beloved queen elizabeth ii
everything could change
you know sometimes people in power
refuse to abide by the rules
but
that's a story
for another
what if